on November 9th 1989 an exhausted East
German bureaucrat misread a memo
regarding the loosening of travel
restrictions prompting thousands of East
Berliners to checkpoints at the Berlin
Wall a monstrous cement barrier which
had kept them locked in for 28 years
Germans call that moment maurer fall and
the peaceful revolution reason TV went
to East Berlin to our Park once the site
of the no-man's land or death strip
where Berliners gathered to watch films
depicting the life and death of what the
East German government called the
anti-fascist barrier each schnitzel
drink beer and remember a bizarre and
tragic time long since passed I wake up
my kids and we went to the Brandenburg
Gate we saw the people climbing on the
wall and picking there and getting
pieces out of it and that was really a
very great moment for young people you
just saw there's always some kind of
other strange kind of Germany there's
rot Sakana it was like coming this guy
who tells you look at this capitalist
how poor they are look at them how they
creepy you know out there you know they
pretend that it's great for all the
working-class people
no but they exploit your soul you know
glowing white balloons traced the path
of where the wall stood and on trendy
Bernauer Strasse photo exhibits depict
cold war events which took place on that
exact spot we want to remember the a
peaceful revolution to the people they
risked their life to overcome their fear
to go on the streets they demonstrate
against the politics in the former GDR
and it was the people say break down
they tear down the wall 25 years ago